yo what's happening reject nation we're
gonna watch the mandalorian season two
episode six today i hear this is the one
robert rodriguez directed i'm super
excited to check it out if you haven't
done so already make sure to subscribe
and click that notification bell to get
notified when our next mandalorian
reaction is up like we've mentioned
before full length reaction watch alongs
where you sync up with the time coder
all over at our patreon page we're over
there we cover many shows with the same
tier
we have the option for reaction
highlights or watch alongs included
shows like supernatural doctor who
jojo's bizarre adventure avatar the last
airbender oh there's a whole bunch of
shows a whole bunch of tv shows all
right
lastly i gotta thank my buddy eric over
at nerd chronic for editing these
reaction highlights for us he puts a lot
of hard work into these to make sure
they can even just get visible on
youtube so thank you so much eric
for all the hard work you do i love you
i want to make love to you one of these
days and then you could edit that video
for us let's finally watch this
i said i says very cool very
very cool some people don't get that
that's red letter medias
go watch the nerd crew yeah you'll be
delighted
grogu
[Laughter]
have we ever heard him laugh before okay
here we go they're playing catch
thank ferric
tank ferric you're very special
kid oh
then jaren doesn't want to let him go
don't you want to learn more of that
jedi stuff
i agreed to take you back to your own
kind no so that's what i need to do
or this stuff if it means we don't get
to hang out that's so conflicted
oh no what don't
don't tell me that what no
hope danny trejo shows up in this
episode all the rubber runners
carla gagina's gonna be here sorry buddy
i can't land on the top
looks like we're gonna have to travel
the last stretch with the windows down
yeah really reclaimed that jet pack this
season
what's going to happen what's going to
happen
does this look jedi to you
yeah rocks
in a cool formation probably gonna lift
some of them yeah
this is the seeing stone are you seeing
anything
hey seen those in clone wars
ahsoka told me all i had to do was get
you here and you'd do the rest
now hold up your end
whoa
no you're gonna have to provide cover
for the next 20 minutes
it's finally happening oh such such
really defined nipple chills at this
very moment
whoa
i've been dragging you mandalorians
[Music]
hell yeah wow if you want my armor
you'll have to peel it off my dead body
not that armor i want my armor are you
mandalorian
i'm a simple man making his way through
the galaxy
like my father before me
that's so cool they combined like two
star wars lines there
what's to stop me from dropping you
right where you stand
because i have a sharp shooter up on
that ridge
fennec and if you remember i don't miss
that's great they brought her back i
love that you were dead
she was left for dead on the sands of
tatwin
yama was given to my father django by
your forebears
oh man [ __ ] go get crazy
oh no oh
yes let's get it home
[Laughter]
this is a bright beautiful day
what the hell oh nevermind oh hell yeah
oh yeah dude
look at him go look at him oh yeah
oh yes
making up for lost time
oh my god he's already so much colder
than he was
no cool
damn damn
yeah come on you got it in you wow
raiders of the lost ark
oh just jump out of the way man
you really feel those it's like a it's
just a warrior yeah
oh
dude
no people just going to keep showing up
i'm just waiting for those death
troopers to come out
you got this
just taking hits
hey but at least the stormtroopers are
hitting something for once
oh [ __ ]
dude
[Music]
this is how you use the armor this is
how you don't look like you're someone's
kid brother
in their big brother's costume
[Music]
dude the boba fett choreography is great
i'm getting out of here what's the
tragedy part
this is [ __ ] awesome it was a tragic
day
for these troopers this is so cool
i love it
yeah he watches
two birds with one highly explosive
stone
oh my god
no
i feel like they've been foreshadowing
that [ __ ] going on
of course have the dark trooper that's
been engaged
so they are dark troopers okay
damn the pulse on this episode yeah
whoa
go oh
no oh no
oh
they're back
my chain code has been encoded in this
armor for 25 years
your father was a foundling yes
then that armor belongs to you you will
ensure the safety of the child
the child's gone and don't know
oh then they could get uh uh kara and
grief
yes yes yeah yeah we're forming a posse
marshall of the new republic she's
joined
next imperial sharpshooter you see a
breakdown of that yeah
yeah but these stripes
i mean there are rules i need to follow
they have the kid
the hell what was i saying about rules
again
hell yeah yes yeah a little grogo
way to go the hell away from me
wait oh no no no
oh no stuart beware of the dark side
grogu
have you ever seen one of these
libelo put an eye off these you'll shoot
your eye out
that guy's gonna die someone needs to
contact luke skywalker
guys
damn yo damn robert rodriguez
yo hey it
he hailed it i feel like i keep saying
this every other episode man with the
action
this season in particular is pretty
mind-blowing
yeah oh my god i'm so impressed so
impressed
remember when phoenix champ people were
like ah she's actually dead people were
bored like
they waste her and then you see her here
sniper rifle gun action she's so great
boba fett
right away like everything about him was
better than
tomorrow morrison's portrayal is django
and attack and
what we got a boba fett in the live
action in in the first uh the second
third movie right he was just so
cool and and rough oh yeah
savage he's really grown from a bounty
hunter to just a flat-out warrior
yeah like really like a barbarian almost
but with the focus
and i love i'm gonna misquote it but i
recognized it when i heard it the
they had they had a two-part like they
combined a line from attack of the
clothes that
jjango said and then he says a line that
luke skywalker said right afterwards in
return of the jedi
and that's so cool that they like
combined it into like one long sentence
yeah one on sentence of referentials
so much to talk about let's get into it
people ah let's do it just wanna make
sure i get this right yeah i'm a simple
man
making his way to the galaxy jango says
that and then like my father before me
like how luke says that you know i think
i love the choice
of using these two lines so much is
because the first time you see tamora
morrison
is as jane gofet in attack of the clones
and then
the last time you see boba fett in the
movies is in return of the jedi
so borrowing from the first and last i
think is a pretty cool easter egg of
sorts
about it that's all i caught on to
break down of the episodes make sure to
subscribe to new rockstars
no i'm sure like even just in that
profile scan of when you find out cara
dune
is part of the new republic now
officially and you're like i don't know
who these characters are but i'm sure
there's some little easter eggs here and
there but this is such
like uh a real-time immediacy type of
episode for the most part you know they
show up at tython you know right when he
gets
to meditating suddenly boba fett shows
up and i love the way
they have fun with the audience because
you know
like you see the slave one ship the
recap at the beginning
how's it going okay maybe fennichand is
alive she hasn't she maybe she is
and you do get the reveal of boba fett
did save her life
and then in order to heal her had to do
some like type of droid installation
repair surgical stuff to her so i don't
know if that makes her
stronger or anything or if it's just a
way to have helped heal her you know all
these
talks and rumors about getting more
focused on boba fett in season three
maybe a boba fett spin-off show i don't
know if it's going to be a series that's
going to be boba fett
and fenik shan but that would be pretty
sweet because
i thought like that not only did they
make boba fett cooler
and better and he feels like such a
lived in performance here they even made
fenix
and that much cooler and like the
escalation of the build was so cool
because when boba fett
and fennick first show up it's like okay
are they going to get into a fight is
this going to be between them what's
boba fett's role going to be is he going
to be kind of like a bad guy of course
he wants his armor but is he going to be
sort of villainous antagonistic in this
episode and then the stormtrooper
started showing up the escalation of the
action scenes
were so damn awesome like
the choreography the set pieces were so
grand
what i loved too was this was the first
time in a very long time where i'm like
damn the stormtroopers seem like they're
putting up a decent fight what we know
of star troopers and how clown on they
are
this is the first time i'm like they're
they're landing a few hits they're
competent enough to make this a tense
fight
yeah there's something about the
quantity of the way they're showing up
seriously robert rodriguez just
commands the camera here when it comes
to uh
direction of the action because yes it's
got some of that like fast-paced
energy that he does provide to his
action scenes also you know he is a fan
of the western genre
obviously uh if you've seen some of his
previous work
you know like shark boy and lava girl
now we can be heroes
coming out soon that kind of like
western type of confrontation at first
with boba fett and in jar and and then
to go into these action set pieces and
honestly the way boba was fighting
surprised me just that raw
type of you know viking-like fighting
style was very surprising just a little
bit of blood that could have been
very gory that could have been very
violent and i love that he br that
robert riga's allowed for that type of
savagery here in this episode well i
think
one thing because i've often found
myself thinking about that as
movies and shows have progressed and as
like pg-13s get harder and more intense
with their depictions of violence and
one thing that struck me in this episode
was that
the violence or at least the action
feels a lot more bone crunching because
you're literally seeing
pieces of those helmets being broken
apart and flying
and even though they're not blood you
know someone's head is getting
crushed in there and there's that one
shot where they even showed just the
aftermath of one of those troopers
laying there and we know the face of
that mask
so well that it's basically like a
person's face and so to see it
warped that way like it really does hit
at a visceral
savagery that yeah does like really come
out through
boba's portrayal here and yeah just the
way he's leveling dudes they're all
in a unit but he's single-handedly when
they focus on
him you know really leveling these guys
and to do something to reintroduce this
character but to also like add
layers and legitimacy in just a small
package i thought they did a really
great job like you pointed out i mean
because he does
feel like a fully fleshed wandering
figure
and his infinix shan's chemistry feels
like they've been together since that
first season episode when he first
appeared in frame and i love those
ways in which they've set these things
up and then paid them off later and the
way that the pacing of the storytelling
of this season has unfolded because
in this episode it kind of struck me the
same way the last one did where it's
like oh man we're getting right
to this next portion and you know that
further reinforces the fact that this
move
season sort of feels like a movie if you
look at it the first chunks the first
couple episodes aren't necessarily the
main plot but they get things going
and then when you arrive at this episode
you know you have that promise of like
oh maybe bubble will show up you know
maybe we'll see certain things and then
you get right to them he puts baby
grogu right on the seeing stone and
immediately that takes off and then
immediately boba fett and fennick show
up and then immediately the stakes that
we've been building with
moff gideon you know start to set in and
it really yeah it feels like they gave
us a nice tease at the top of the season
and now they're really
smartly introducing all these things
that people have been anticipating
yeah it's not just making this season
start to come together i mean it is i've
been loving this season since the first
episode of it
but it's even complimenting even more so
the first season and making that feel
more whole
you're getting the full story of the
mandalorian not just
the season two story it's it's
really tying everything up i love the
structure of this one you start off
right away picking up from how
danjarin learned the name of grogu and
the way he's having fun with him and
calling him in and watching him just
react and respond to him the
pain that you can sense underneath the
helmet of
how he doesn't want to let him go and
just the fact that he even had so much
more dialogue than jaren before boba
fett showed up the dialogue that he was
expressing towards grogu he just seems
like he's become a real father yeah to
the point
like he's just talking with him so much
this man who's used to being alone all
the time and probably never really
spoke much while on these various
travels and missions
anyway yeah now is finding a reason to
be very emotional they're setting up how
the heartbreak of what's to come like
that's the tragedy of having to
the feeling of despair and lost it is
gonna that that he will lose groggy by
the end of this episode because you know
when is it tragic i'm like
i don't know what's tragic here this is
pretty awesome this is great looks like
they're winning and knocking this out of
the park
except you know that it's not yeah i
mean i'm hoping that like while i
thought
fennick sham was exceptionally cooler
this time around and hoping we get to
uncover more layers about her actual
character persona what tomorrow
morrison's portrayal of boba fett so far
uh at least which is with this one
episode alone like within the action
there's a performance there it's not
just cold and he's badass
he's letting out the pain you know he's
letting out that rage and fury and you
could feel this sort of
conflict about his past honoring his
legacy he was so attached to jango fett
but then also
like when he is in the armor which by
the way was just such a great moment
like it was so cool and i love how in
the first episode of this you see cobb
in the outfit and he clearly doesn't
know how to take full advantage of this
yeah it looks like woody the cowboy from
toy story
with a mandalorian helmet shoved on but
but even with
using it he doesn't quite know how to
take advantage of it whereas here bubba
just slips
right into it and he just starts doing
all these cool ass things
yeah that you know oh yeah oh god i
don't think cobb even knew how to do
some of this you know well that was a
great like especially too with the
stakes of like the razor
crest getting blown to smithereens that
one little moment like i love a little
magic moment like that where he peers
the door he's like oh the ship's open
yeah
i know where to go and then you know
making that the payoff of like he's
already been
such an impact on this episode and then
having him show up
in the armor and reclaiming you know the
heavily debated badass status yeah
that's a great point because you get so
invested into him without the armor and
seeing
this sort of haunted character and then
to get him back in the armor he's like
sweet but when he's going up
in the slave one ship and and he's
tracked you you could feel there's
something different about it
you can feel more of a compassionate
side than him this time around yeah
in the clone wars they do have those
boba fett episodes so you do get
different layers of them there but i'm
talking about leaving off of where we
got him in
you know empire strikes back and
returning to the jedi where we were with
that character at that point and then
here you do get this additional
compassion inside to him you could hear
it in the way he
not only in the deal that he wants to
honor but in the way they talk about the
child the way he interacts with fenix
shand
having to go track down the child when
the death and the dark troopers uh grab
grogo there's such a great capture in
his voice when he does see the ship
and you could feel that that like shock
almost as
uh fear element of the empire's
back and like that just sent chills
throughout my body of him
realizing it that that emotional moment
for boba fett having to deal with that
you know that's what i mean the conflict
of his past i've had there's parts he
wants to honor parts that he's married
to and loves and there's other parts
where
you could feel this sense of like i'm
not sure if the right word is shame but
there is definitely this element of him
of
just haunted there's a yeah there's a
haunted pain
aspect there and probably some
unfinished business for sure and and one
thing i
i really too liked is we've been talking
throughout the season about how they're
slowly challenging dinjarin's just
adherence to the mandalorian codes and
whatnot
this felt nice to me because it really
seemed like in very subtle ways he and
boba fett kind of resonate just as
as people a little bit right right they
did a good job at establishing because
people have constantly go back and forth
well you know
django fed he wasn't real mandalorian
you know so they did a great job with
the with the exchange here of going no
he deserves the armor boba fett
deserves this armor it's not ju i
thought there might be a like a major
conflict about that but they had a
really nice explanation and you're like
especially talking about finding in the
mandalorian wars and
stuff like that i was like all right
yeah yeah okay cool we'll wrap that up
vindication moment where he gets to show
him he's like see it belonged to
your father before me yeah exactly
exactly it was it was a really solid
wrap up on that they're gonna be teaming
up
that's cool bill burr's coming back bill
mayfield is coming back
dark troopers were i'm not familiar
i'm like i i don't know them all right
i'm just gonna put that out i don't know
what
they are they were like menacing iron
man machines what i thought i heard the
riff in my head as they were descending
please feel free to elaborate more on
them uh for those who are familiar with
them because i'm not but
yeah these like imposing droid like
troopers pretty scary stuff
you know they they don't they're
definitely not going to be as easy to
take down as there are storm troopers
and then of course moff gideon you know
taunting
toying with their donor
oh yeah with grogood like that was so
sad i got concerned because like as much
as groga was like
messing with them and then also the talk
of what ahsoka tano was
speaking about with her worry of having
grogu trained of the temptation of what
could lead him to the dark side when he
is messing with them
and moff gideon is just letting him do
it like no
no let him do his thing that had me
concerned of yeah oh no
no this is this this is the kind of
thing that could lead grogu to the dark
side
and that's a moment that forces you as
an audience member to catch yourself
because part of you is with grogu you're
like yeah beat him up
yeah you know we're we're hurting for
you and we're hurting for tinjarin but
also i mean like giancarlo esposito i
think is my favorite instance of
typecasting
because like this is he brings different
shades to every villain he plays
yeah and even in that swift little
moment
and and i love that they paid so much
attention to him just walking
to that room yeah really just building
up his presence and his contrast from
everybody else in the room he really
brings a very calm but very terrifying
energy
he commands the screen effortlessly i
mean watching him and grogu
interact with each other was scary
it's it's a menacing it's a menacing
moment and him just taunting him with
the dark saber too
yeah it looks like he really just wants
you to encourage him to go full-on
yeah you know like um taking to dr
pershing
we gotta see what's what's in store next
and then i thought carradoon and grief
cargo were going to be like all right
let's all team up we're a big ensemble
team now gotta go help out the baby
you know i thought that's what it was
gonna be yeah that could be how the next
episode starts you never know
i mean somehow something's gotta we're
leading at something bigger
especially because i think the carrot
dude they kind of do it in passing
with like yeah marshall with the new
republic now it's a little bit in
passing
uh you know like oh but we're setting up
to get to mayfield based off of how
cara dune had that big scene in the the
fourth episode
when being talked about joining the
empire
on the rise again the birth of the first
order yeah all these things
i think what i'm trying to get at is i
feel like this show is called the
mandalorian but it's within the star
wars universe
and i feel like we're on the verge of
getting some real war [ __ ]
yeah yeah some star wars [ __ ]
underline the wars yeah because i mean
no matter what this means that at least
some type of republic resources exactly
helping this mission to retrieve the
child from the empire and that's direct
conflict either way
even if it's on jinjaren's behalf you
know i don't know which is my favorite
episode the soca one or this one i mean
this is shorter
and because i love ahsoka tano i i'm
god it doesn't matter just watch it so
i'm like this is so bad
every episode is the best episode and i
hope rodriguez gets one for season three
oh he is undoubtedly yeah
no i i believe that's confirmed already
awesome guys leave your thoughts down
below clarify anything you want what a
little easter eggs did you guys pick up
on i don't know what those butterflies
are called i recognize them from clone
wars maybe they're just called blue
butterflies i don't know what they are
subscribe click that notification bell
you can check us
on patreon thanks again eric over at
nerdcraft for editing this video for us
last but not least
eric horstmann man how cool was that it
was that was
that was such a great episode of course
it
eric a couple weeks ago was like hey do
you think i got time to finish the clone
wars
and he didn't even start it yet and now
he's finished clone wars
and rebels that is so much television
i'm sitting here doing the math now i'm
like how many episodes a day did you
watch
that is did you sleep at like 10 seasons
of television
that is crazy dude congratulations and i
know it's making the mandalorian
experience that much better for you when
i was talking with you recently
i didn't realize how much of a love you
did have for star wars for some reason i
was under the impression he didn't
really care for it
and then getting to talk to him like oh
damn star wars actually means a lot to
you and i didn't realize that
so dude i'm so happy that you are having
this rewarding experience right now in
some ways i feel like we are both we are
grogus to you
i know you call me greg you the way i
like it gregoo
and you are our mandalorian that
protects us and i appreciate that i
really feel like you take care of us in
a lot of ways and you look after both
john and i
i actually mean that sincerely this
could easily just be a joke no it's true
have you seen our live streams you take
care of us
you take care of us better than most
people and if someone decides to like
attack us or get mean on us you like go
to bat for us you are a
warrior you you are you are boba fett in
this episode
just like decimate even if you disagree
with us but someone
attacks us on it you will just go to bed
and i love that about you
unconditional support no matter what
you're the best man and i hope you're
able to have a merry christmas this year
2020 has been rough but you've helped
make 2020 a much better year for us
sincerely mean that thank you